okay good evening everybody and welcome
to planning and development management
committee my name is aiden williams i'm
the
chair of the committee also on this call
will be
ben hartley who serves as the vice chair
senior officers from our
legal planning and democratic services
division
at the council offices from the highways
authority
and the members who make up the planning
and development management committee
just before we begin i'd just like to
read a short
statement outlining the webcasting
process for this evening
for your information this meeting has
been live streamed and recorded so
please mute your microphones to minimize
background noise
if you wish to speak on an item please
use the chat facility to notify me
and then wait until i invite you to
speak before making your comments
please state your name um now turning to
the
business uh agenda item one is to notice
attendances
councillor carey has submitted apologies
and i understand that council holden is
substituting
in his place councillor hartley and
councillor dr barkley have notified that
they are running late for the committee
meeting but they are hoping to join us
later on and um i understand that
councillor senate has not submitted
apologies and is not presently on the
call
but hopefully he will be joining us and
agenda item number two is to note
membership of committee
taking that is noted and agenda item
three is the appointment of the
subcommittee
and that is the subcommittee for the
town village green
subcommittee typically compromising the
chair vice chair and opposition
spokesperson or their nominees
and can i take it that that's approved
agenda item number four is to know terms
of reference for the committee
and similarly agenda item five is to
note the meeting dates
turning to agenda writing number six are
declarations of interest are there any
members wishing at this point to declare
an interest
i do chair um last
item on the application to develop 42
church road i um call this in and i'll
be speaking against the officer
recommendation
so i will not participate in the
committee
discussion and i won't be voting thank
you
councillor holden can i is that also the
case for yourself similar absolutely the
same situation
but with five pinewood
in my in my award
thank you councilman um agenda item
number seven
is minutes of the hebrews meeting um
i'm happy to move chair thank you
councillor
um can we confirm if those are approved
yeah no objections okay fantastic uh
agenda item seven uh
gender item eight is questions from from
members of the public
i understand that we have not received
any um
questions prior to the meeting
and then agenda item nine additional
information report that should have been
circular well it has been circulated by
your email to members
and trust that you've all received that
and we can now proceed on to
the business of the meeting determining
the applications
the first application that is going to
be considered is
14 plane tree road which is on page 76
of your agenda
pack um before we turn to the discussion
or representations
we're going to receive a short officer
introduction from ms milner
please thank you chair um i hope you can
all
hear me and i'm just going to share my
screen so you can see the
presentation
[Music]
can you all see the pdf
yes and can you see my cursor my music
here sir
just in case uh thank you
so the application first application
before members this evening
relates to 14 plane tree road known as
cassell
the site comprises a two-story detached
residential property
located on located on the south side of
plane tree road
in the south hale conservation area the
proxy was constructed in the 1930s and
has since been
extended to the side along with um a
double garage to the front which you can
see here
the site features a front guardian front
driveway rear patio and garden
and following water damage is currently
um
unoccupied waiting refurbishment
neighboring properties are entirely
residential and
are boarded by hedges and some trees to
the rear
the site and as well as being within the
south hail conservation area
is adjacent to grade two listed
buildings to the rear
um namely 119 and one two one park road
both of which are edgar wood properties
dating from the early 20th century
there are other listed buildings within
the vicinity but these two
um adjoin the rear property boundary
and the application property is not
identified as being a positive
contributor within the conservation area
this is the existing floor plan of the
property
and then i move on to the proposal the
application sees planning permission for
the remodeling of the existing
properties with extensions and
alterations to the form and appearance
this includes the demolition of these
existing garages and chimney stack
and the erection of a part single part
two-story front extension
single-story rear extensions with
alterations to the roof shape to include
an
increase in the side roof height there
would be one
front and two rear dormers along with a
roof light
to accommodate the loft conversion there
would also be a new chimney replacement
windows a rear juliet balcony and front
and rear
basement and light wells objections have
been received
um so this is the floor plans objections
have been received from four neighboring
properties
citing concerns over over development of
the site scale and design of the apple
of the proposal the impact on their
amenity particularly from
overlooking and sense of it being
overbearing and an impact on the
listed buildings we've also received
representation from councillors young
and mitchell in support of
the local residents objecting to the
proposal and also from the edgar woods
society
and objecting to the proposal and
voicing concerns not only to the impact
on the
adjacent listed buildings but the
conservation area as a whole
and also laying out their assessment of
the application property
so the key things to consider are the
impact
upon the character and significance of
the conservation area and the listed
buildings and their settings
the design and appearance of the
proposal
the impact of enabling amenity trees and
ecology
officers do acknowledge this is a a
large change to the existing property
however
the value we place on the existing
property does not align with that of the
local residents or the edgar wood
society we consider that the extensions
to the property and alterations
have um reduced its value that it plays
to the conservation area
and that consider that although the
extensions to the property
would change the form and appearance
that they would improve the aesthetic
value within the street scene
and we have taken on board the concerns
of the society
and local residents and amendments to
the scheme have been sought
in regards to the additional information
report
i would note that we have proposed to
amend the materials condition
to insist that samples are provided of
all materials along with specifications
and also
requested further architectural
detailing and
section drawings at a larger scale to
ensure that the dormers
that are proposed on the rear alongside
every other feature is of
the necessarily necessary quality
we do recognize that there will be a
substantial increase on in the massing
and therefore we have
cited that there would be a degree of
harm to the conservation area as a whole
however this is classed as less than
substantial harm in accordance with the
mppf
being at the lesser end of the scale of
harm and it's considered that this harm
as a result of the massing is outweighed
by the increased value that the property
could play within the wider conservation
area
by improvements to the architectural
integrity
and aesthetics of the property in
regards the listed buildings
we do not agree with the edgar wood
society and consider that
considering that the change in land
levels with the edgar wood properties
being at a higher level
and the separation distances between the
properties and the scale of the
changes to the rear of the property that
the
changes to the property would not harm
the setting of that list of
those listed buildings and in regards to
the impact on amenity
and these are dually noted and because
of that we have proposed conditions
and seal glazing windows that look
towards number 16 plane tree road and
also obscure glazing and fixing ship the
dormer
closest to plane tree road number 16
plane tree road
however overall we do consider that the
harm to the conservation area is
outweighed by the public benefits of the
improvements
to the property and therefore it is
considered unbalanced that the proposal
is acceptable and according to policy
and subject to the conditions
we do recommend approval
thank you i just note sorry just one
last point to note
on the photographs and there has been
some comments about the cgi's that have
been submitted and i think this will be
a point that's raised throughout the
committee
any cgi's that are submitted either by
objectives
or applicants in our support or
objection to a scheme
and our cgi's they are graphical
representations they are not taken as
approved documents um there are cgi's
with this scheme that aren't on the
presentation but they are
available on the website to view and
should members wish
thank you thank you ms mona um i
understand there's three people
wishing to speak against the application
uh
mr mike williams councillor mitchell and
councillor mrs young
has there been any discussion as to
who's hoping to speak first
is is mr williams on the in the meeting
yes i'm i'm present are you happy to
i will unless councillor young would
like to speak first
no i think you would better speak first
mr williams
okay thank you just to let you know mr
williams you have three minutes to speak
um to time if not we'll just gently uh
request that you wrap up your comments
thank you
okay uh good afternoon everybody my name
is mike williams
i've been asked to speak on behalf of
the four neighbours of the
subject property each side and two at
the rear
together also representing the edgar
woods society
the council has a legal duty to pay
special attention to preserving historic
houses in the conservation area
as correctly stated in the offices
report however
the plumbing department did not demand a
significant statement to be submitted
with this application
as required under the nppf
consequently the historical and
architectural significance of the
building
has been has not been assessed and the
officer's report
is deeply flawed in this in its
conclusion
this house is in fact of considerable
historic and architectural interest
the ethical wood society has established
that the house lies within the parcel of
land forming the richardson estate which
has allocated to eliquid
was allocated to headquarter to design
although slightly younger than the
neighboring listed buildings
it was more than likely designed by the
edgar wood architectural practice
this information has not been taken into
consideration by the officer
the the plain clean lines of the
building reflect the modern style of
edgard
and his architectural partner henry
sellers it was a very modern building
when it was
designed in 1930 and can often be
mistaken for
buildings constructed in the 1950s
the author of the edgar woods submission
is recognized as the leading
authority on edgard's buildings to the
extent that the manchester university
and john ryland's library
club published his 12 000 word academic
paper on this very subject
contrary to the officer's report the
building is still in its original form
as indicated on the 1936 ordnance survey
map
it will be a tragedy to destroy this
striking house in the interest of an
over development of the roof space
involving several second floor door
windows on suitable bifold doors
juliet balcony and an excessive rear
extension
this building deserves a great deal more
sympathetic attention
if it is to be altered in any way
finally the council did not demand
as the council did not demand a
significant statement and the edgar wood
report failed to achieve
sufficient consideration in the office
report
should the proposal be approved i feel
that the council would not have met its
legal duty
of paying special attention to
preserving the heritage of the
conservation area
may i ask that you reject this
application on the ground as
unsympathetic
and over development and prevent the
destruction of a building that can
present a far better case for formal
listing
than rebuilding please can you help to
ensure that the building is given a
chance to survive
thank you
thank you mr williams um councillor mrs
young
are you happy to speak next yes
thank you for letting me you have five
minutes to speak thank you
yeah that's fine fourteenth planetary
road as you've seen on the map is built
right up to the boundary
of sixteenth entry road and within and
is within the south hale conservation
area
in hell central we are the custodians of
part of the south
ale conservation area and we are proud
that this area of the road
contains the largest cluster of edgar
wood houses in the united
kingdom edgar wood was born in 1860
and died in 1935. he is credited with
having as many as 30 of his buildings
formally lifted the being of
architectural interest
and the edgar wood society have told us
that there is a possibility
that number 14 plane tree road is the
last building in trafford built to his
design
we are fortunate in possessing a cluster
of some seven of these buildings
all of which are now grade two listed
that were built immediately close to
each other
the proposed extensions to 14 plane tree
road
or exactly up to the boundary of sixteen
planetary road
immediately adjacent to these houses
it's our duty to preserve these houses
and their environment for the future
and it is as important to protect the
outside area
of these houses which were designed
following the architectural developments
of william morris's arts and crafts
movement
which inspired edgar wood as well as the
interiors
our heritage officer is on record as
saying that she's uncomfortable with
this proposed development
as it will cause minor harm to the
character and appearance of 14 planetary
road
and the contribution it makes to the
south hale conservation area as a whole
this over development of the site will
cause more than
minor harm to the dwellings immediately
adjacent to it
should this development go ahead
neighboring houses will be both
overlooked and overshadowed
by a development which would erode the
spacious character
and appearance of this important part of
the scout hail conservation area
the heritage officer has also stated
that this home should be assessed on the
paragraph 196
of the nppf which states that where a
development performance
will lead to less than substantial harm
to the significance of a designated
heritage asset
this home should be weighed against the
public benefits of a proposal
including where appropriate securing its
optimum
viable use i don't see any public
benefits in arriving in allowing this
application
only private profit allowing this
development would destroy the
spaciousness aspects
of this area completely and be
absolutely contrary to the concept of a
conservation
you as members of the planning committee
are also custodians of the conservation
areas of trafford
and will be answerable to future
residents of trafford
this application will result in over
development of the site
and i would like future resident
residents
to be able to thank you for preserving
their heritage
by refusing inappropriate developments
such as this one
thank you thank you councillor mrs young
councillor mitchell
are you with us
i uh actually
having uh heard both the previous uh
um speakers i don't think that i can
really
uh expand any further but i do
ask the committee to please consider
very carefully
uh what has been suggested because we
we ought to be able to protect our
environment
and this is a prime clay
case of actually doing good instead of
damaging it
that was all thank you mr chairman
thank you councillor mitchell um
speaking
in favor of the application is uh mr
michael tutti he's mr tutti
it's good evening mr good game thank you
thank you mr tutti we'll have three
minutes to speak if you want to
start your contribution thank you thank
you chair for the opportunity to speak
in support of our application
we are a family with young sons at early
primary school age that already live
within the trafford area and we
purchased 14 plain tree road in early
2018
for this to be our long-term family home
whilst we could save funds and remodel
and refurbish the property
we rented the house out for a short time
but unfortunately
during the tenancy the property became
unoccupied and uninhabitable following a
major water leak event in early 2019
the damage was also further escalated
through no fault of our own
as we were denied access for a long
period following the leak
and it was required to carry out
extensive internal works to mitigate the
damage
given the situation of now having a
damaged and uninhabitable
empty building and as the property is
not a positive contributor
to the architectural heritage of the
area as detailed in the conservation
area management plan
we could have sought to demolish the
property and replace it with a new build
which many others may have done instead
we wish to reuse and retain the majority
of the existing house and its original
features
while sympathetically refurbishing
remodeling
and adding some additional space
our planning application journey for the
proposed refurbishment and remodeling
commenced on the 12th of december 2019
almost a full year today since we
submitted our initial scheme
the jerk this journey has included the
withdrawal of
withdrawal of our initial scheme at the
request of the council
a pre-application process where the
council provided detailed
guidance on how to amend our scheme in
accordance with the planning guidelines
a changing planning officers mid
application
and extensive dialogue with these
planning officers as well as
consultation with the conservation
officer
throughout this process we are
proactively engaged and worked hard with
both our architects
and the planning officers to respond to
all requests made of us to meant to
amend our design
the outcome is that we have now jointly
reached a proposed scheme which meets
the planning guidelines
addresses the various concerns stated in
the planning application letter
and the conservation officer heritage
comments
the proposed scheme is being recommended
by the planning officers to grant
approval
and we kindly request the committee
supports this recommendation
thank you chair thank you mr tutti and
just before we move to
the discussion i think ms kowali has
indicated like to me
provide some clarification
not me chairman i think i want to do
that and just to clarify a couple of
points that i think is important to
to know um an assess heritage statement
was submitted with this application
it's a 23-page document that is on the
council's website
and whilst it may come to a different
conclusion to
to others objecting they have um
noted the mppf and it has been prepared
by um
a planner and also just to point out
that the development
is not right up to the boundary it has
been set off the boundary of number 16
and is set fair away than the existing
garages and although still close to the
boundary it is not
immediately adjacent to it thank you
thank you ms milner and council
accordingly i think you've indicated
you're happy to be in the discussion
yeah uh thank you chair um i cycled over
to this property
yesterday um it's not a particularly
impressive
property um i've read the
report from edward woods society
and at best they point to it
a likelihood of it being designed by
uh somebody who used to work with edward
wood
uh john uh j henry seller
i don't i went to the other properties
uh the
the the genuine edward wood and they're
of a different class all together
and i think we're really stretching it
here to extend the edward
edward wood franchise onto this property
um i i do i do i i i do think planners
have taken this very seriously and
addressed that and i think they've given
a good report and they've worked with
the uh
the uh the homeowner so i'm happy to
propose
i don't think it's one that we want to
hold back
uh because of links with somebody who
worked with somebody
i'm not um i i'd much prefer just to
give permission
for this to be developed and brought
back into use
thank you chair and i'm happy to propose
thank you councillor accordingly and
councillor morgan you've indicated as
well
thank you chair um i've come to a bit of
a different conclusion than council
accordingly
um if this was in any other part of the
borough
i i wouldn't really be probably i
probably wouldn't have
really any comments on it um it is a
substantial
development um i think anyone um
would argue looking at the plans would
say that and i know it's been seen it's
been stated it's refurbishment i mean
there's a significant rebuild
required of this property but it does
concern me about it being in the in the
heritage conservation
and south south isle conservation area
and i don't want to i mean i
i i do not know um um
the the details of history as much as
others but
i'm just getting it's just reading one
the heritage officer um
stated that it's um that the building
in their view will over develop this
dwelling
and the contribution that makes the
south health conservation know whilst
the existing extension is a poor
addition this shouldn't be taken as
excuse making matters worse
um particularly in terms of the roof and
the chimney
um i mean councillor young stated in
terms of
it is harm in accordance with the mppf
it should be therefore weighted
against the public benefit i'm not sure
what public benefit is of making such a
substantial development
i i understand that it needs developing
but i'm not ensure this has to be the
case
um i'm not if i'm honest i'm i'm gonna
then conclude and say i haven't really
decided i'm quite interested in what
other committee members have to say
um but it really does concern me about
the heritage statement and
this is a substantial rebuild of the
property and i i
i am not the one to judge but the
heritage officer has said it does it
impact it it's really for the committee
members to decide on whether that
is enough um of an impact i'm
currently going to set the fence um but
um i do have real concerns on this
on this statement thanks chef thank you
councillor councillor winston
indicated as well yes thank you chad
this is a tough one this
but i mean as we've said in um in
many of these meetings before it's all
about balance isn't it
and my instinct is to see if it's
something in the conservation areas it
should be conserved
and yet also when i saw the building
i wasn't impressed by the it didn't
stand out as being worthy of
conservation if that makes sense it
wasn't but
it wasn't um
an individual enough building and then i
saw the way the
the um the the planning balance had been
reached and i recognized that the
the heritage officer did have some
concerns around this
but the planning team judged that the
the home would be less of substantial
and then balance that against the public
benefit
and i also note that the the input from
the
the owners who have worked very closely
with our own planning team
to arrive at a design which is
acceptable to us
and we must give some weight to the the
willingness
and of them to accept that advice so i
think i've just have to say order that
one's a tough one i'm happy to second
that we go with officer's recommendation
and
grant this application for the the
reasons which which i've just been
through
thank you chair thank you councillor and
councillor rigby i think your hand is up
thank you i won't repeat what's been
said there's been
some um really good arguments put
forward on both sides
um i've really studied this application
at length
it's a difficult one but what's swaying
me is that
the substantial rebuild is obviously
necessary
and what is
comforting is that the applicant
i know it has worked with officers over
quite a
time to overcome and agree areas
which were of concern um
and what has been decided would do
little harm
to the conservation area which i agree
i'm all in favor of
retaining conservation areas through the
maximum wherever possible
but on occasions we've got to be a tad
flexible
so in light of this
i can't find a clear and definite reason
for supporting any refusal
thank you councilman and that no one
else indicating in the
chat function is anybody else wishing to
um contribute to the discussion
no i mean i i think many of his best
counseling has done the use sort of
summed it up first when he said that
these questions in
in respective heritage i always come
down to a judgment about balance
and what's reasonable and i think to my
mind it's highlighted in paragraph 41
of the report that actually the increase
in the footprint
of the proposed development isn't that
significant
um it's highlighted in paragraph 51 that
it is a high quality development that's
proposed here
and i think with that in mind uh and
hearing that the heritage officer has
only assessed the um
the level of harm would be minor um i i
find myself in agreement with them
the contributions we've heard from
councillor rugby when stanley
and accordingly now with no one else
indicating that they'd like to
contribute i suggest that as it's been
proposed in the second juvenile move to
the vote on this item
and so i will as you appear on my screen
i i will uh ask you to just confirm
verbally
how you'd like to vote and whether or
not you are in support or opposing
the officer recommendation to grant
permission
and counselor rigby my support
thank you councillor
a tough one but i've decided to go
against officer recommendation
and refuse counselor thomas
i support the recommendation thank you
councillor councillor
stanley support the officer
recommendation to grant chair thank you
thank you councillor minis
i think it's a close one but i think i'm
going to go in support thank you
thank you councillor councillor proctor
recommendation thank you councillor
council accordingly support chair
thank you councillor councillor morgan
thank you chair again tough one uh but i
think i'm gonna go against officer
recommendations on this one
thank you and councillor holden
i tend to agree with uh council morgan i
will vote against it
uh okay and myself i will be voting
uh in support of office and
recommendation to grant so i make that
as this application having been improved
uh the next application that we will
turn to
is 231b hail road
which is on page 55 of the committee
report and before we hear
representations there will be an
introduction
provided by ms milner
thank you just sorry just about me a
second i'm just getting the uh
presentation
available
can you see the start of the
presentation
on my cursor
that's great thank you um
so um
similar to the previous application um
this application relates to 231b
hail road also in there the south hale
conservation area
and site comprises a two-story detached
property
and features a french rivalry shared
with the adjacent property of 231
and an attachable garage with hit roof
large rear garden
and several trees and boundaries are
formed by a mixture of
um hedges bushes and trees and name
bring properties are all residential
although located within the south hale
conservation area
and and behind again several listed
properties
this was actually built and the property
was built in the early 2000s
but in a style to complement the wider
area
and the application seeks um extensions
to the
front side and rear and over the
existing garage and
and to the rear two stories to the rear
and to the side with
extensions to the roof and also juliet
balcony
um we have again and on this one
received quite a
number of rejections six or more
objections from properties
to the rear and side along grange avenue
and residents are particularly concerned
about the scale of the proposals and
overlooking from
the extensions the impact of the
increase in the built form
and massing and the negative impact on
the
listed houses on hail road and the
proximity to the side and boundary
include and also the the loss of
spaciousness and removing of trees
um properties on grange road
are particularly concerned that the
proposal will not um
preserve the the character of the
conservation area
officers um also note that there has
been um a
previous refusal on this site in 2011
and this was um dismissed appeal meaning
that the
inspector agreed it should be refused
however and
importantly to note um the inspector did
conclude that extensions to the property
then did not harm
the setting of the listed buildings just
to note the list of buildings are
along here um apologies this
is the existing site plan this is the
existing property as you can see
you have the garage to the front that
projects out
and the proposal is to extend along the
side here
going over the garage and up to the side
here in filling sections
and a two-story extension to this
section here and to
the rear and officers
have considered the the impact on the
conservation area and again it is noted
that the conservation officer has
um does consider this to be um
of concern and has again cited it to
have less than substantial harm on the
couch of the conservation area
because of the loss of spaciousness to
the site
and considers that the proposals do not
go far enough
um beyond the previous refusal to
address her concerns
officers have given significant
consideration to this application
and we continue to conclude that there
would be
no harm to the listed buildings as the
proposal does not
um increase the massing towards the
front any further than the previous
refuse scheme
in regards to the conservation area we
now conclude that because of the change
in the massing that
moves more of the massing to the rear
rather than the side although there will
still be extensions to the side
that that spaciousness to the side of
the property and a character of the
conservation area
is um significantly maintained
in regards to the loss of trees there is
no objection from from our tree offices
they can sit and
the loss of trees is is minimal and in
regards to amenity
we consider that and given the the
significant um separation distances to
the rear properties on grange avenue and
that any windows on the side above
ground floor would be
obscure glazed we have concluded that on
balance
that they would not be harm to the
conservation area or the listed
buildings
that it is of an acceptable design and
scale and that the impacts on the
amenity
of um adjacent residents would
on balance be acceptable therefore
subject to the conditions as outlined in
the committee report we do
recommend approval thank you chair
and again just to pick up finally sorry
about the cgi
this cgi was submitted with um
from one of the objectives however this
is not a verified view
this was not assessed as part of the
application um and i know that was sent
on to to members
okay thank you thank you ms milner
um i have donna speaking against the
application
uh councillor mrs young and lindsay
humblet
um has there been any agreement about
who'd like to speak first
i think um i'm going to speak first is
that right councillor that's fine
thank you three minutes to speak and if
you win over time we'll just politely
request that you've applied thank you
thank you chair
okay the um good afternoon everybody the
proposed development raises two
principal
issues the impacts of the development
would have on heritage considerations
um and also the impacts on the immunity
of nearby residents um the the the
images that
um that uh miss milner has put up there
i think you've got five
you should have five slides that have
been sent on that we've produced
and i'm going to talk you through those
points around scale massing and the
impact
on on the neighbors and the harm to the
wider conservation area so the first
diagram is a plan
which is planned just uh which shows the
the footprint
of the proposals and takes away
any of the ambiguity that we thought
there was around the original drawings
um it's um the the blue the blue line
shows the
the extent of the new extension and then
the black line dotted line on there
illustrates the the original 2011
application which showed it's slightly
wider to the side but there was no
extension to the rear on the 2011 and
that's clear
on this plan you can see how it extends
out to the rear
um this was refused obviously as
mentioned and undismissed that appeal
in 2011 um with the consideration that
it would be harmful to the character and
appearance of the conservation area
and would result in a loss to local
residents um
i think arguably the the residents are
saying that this
is arguable now that this is there's
even greater um
impact uh and it should be just
dismissed uh
again on that on that basis also as part
of proposals a large tree
um a prunus while cherry is to be
removed
um now now in theory that the tree
itself is not a great specimen however
it's it's removal and the the the
condition about
having a landscape plan um
should be submitted now speaking as a
professional as a landscape architect
any any mitigation i don't believe
within the boundary between 2 meters and
2.6 meters
you could get no mitigation in there
with a tree without encroaching onto
third-party land
and during this the last eight months in
terms of the planning process there's
been no dialogue by the applicant with
any of the neighbours to discuss
this point um as a principle
the second diagram is the end elevation
which is the flat elevation from grange
avenue
in terms of scale and massing of the
existing building um the
house is large but its scale and mass is
broken by the different roof lines this
is the present elevation
which is very similar to some of the
edgar wood architectural style
the the come proposals seek to change
that with the introduction of a
simplified roof form
and much of the bulk is most evident on
this north west elevation which will
create a very dominant uncharacteristic
feature
in addition the proposals will extend
another four meters to the
along into the back garden so it's it's
going to be
20 um nearly 23 meters long as an
elevation
um which we feel is very out of keeping
with the the design of the house and and
within the conservation area
the third diagram is the rear elevation
which you
you have which looks at the back of the
house essentially um
the built footprint would increase on
the plan by
23.5 now go back to 2011 and it was 18
so it's it's a significant increase over
that
um and you can also see that the
extension now is extending over the
ridge line the higher level of the house
so that's crazy
you could just sort of make it be
concluding
images which which are the slides which
show the visuals so there's the existing
visual
showing the blue line and then there is
the view from
one of the properties on grange avenue
that shows the bulk of massing as a
white block model
the building has been modeled from the
architectural plans
and i think i think it describes um
visually the the impact and the reason
why all of the residents along grange
avenue are
objecting to this application um
we've i think during the planning
process i under the residents have
carefully considered the numerous
amendments on this scheme and we've
discussed this scheme at length together
i think i speak on behalf of all the
residents who've made their
representations expressing their
opposition to the scheme
thank you thank you thank you very much
much appreciated
thanks um councillor mrs young are you
happy to now speak
thank you again mr chairman for letting
me speak
should this new extension to 231b hail
road be allowed
it will loom over the surrounding fence
and probably cause a claustrophobic
feeling
to anyone looking at it from the gardens
in grange road
a two-story side extension and front
garage extension to this house
was refused as you've heard in 2011
and went to an appeal which was
subsequently dismissed
this appeal included a two-story side
extension with the first floor
element in closer proximity to the
northwest boundary
and also included a large garage
extension with
raised roof leaves and ridge heights in
2011 the inspector considered
that the proposed previous scheme would
have adverse
impact on the living conditions of these
residents
within their gardens the inspector noted
that a number of the rear boundaries
were open
2 2 3 1 b the proposed extension would
bring the first floor of the dwelling
closer to the boundary
the inspector then concluded that
consequently
because of its scale mass detailed
design
and proximity to the appeal site
boundary
the proposal will appear extremely
dominant and oppressive
and have a detrimental effect on living
conditions
within the gardens of nearby dwellings
the fact that the first floor will now
be slightly less close to the boundary
does not take away from the fact that
the development overall
will be between 2 and 2.6 meters
and extending 4 meters from the existing
rear elevation
the northwest elevation has little
relief
with an extensive largely blank wall
and large roof it will appear as an
oppressive overbearing mass
for the surrounding for the surrounding
residents
the comments of the inspector therefore
still apply
we are told that section 72 of the
planning act 1990
requires local planning authorities to
pay special attention
in the exercise of planning functions to
the desirability of preserving
or enhancing the character of a
conservation area
and not to allow any adverse impacts
which would significantly
and demonstrably outweigh the benefits
the special interest of the conservation
area is enhanced by the cumulative
effect
created by its spaciousness the mature
landscaping and the compatibility
of natural and man-made features the
failure of the applicant to address the
concerns raised by the inspector
and the overall inappropriateness of the
current proposals
or shared by the council's conservation
officer
who states there is now a marginal
reduction in the extensions proposed to
the northwest
elevation which are welcomed however
this is still an increase in built form
towards the northwest side boundary
the scheme now proposes a substantial
two-story projection
to the north elevation this will
increase the amount of build form along
the side boundary
however when comparing the previously
refused scheme
with the current proposals i failed to
see how these latest provisions
address the concerns raised by the
inspector
in respect of development so close to
the side boundary
he considered the development would
erode the spacious character
and appearance of the south hale
conservation area
these views of the conservative office
of the conservation officer
should not be ignored and this proposal
rejected
due to the adverse impact that this over
development would have
on the conservation area we are lucky in
trafford
but we possess a number of beautiful
homes
this area around hale road has a large
cluster of houses
designed by architects such as edgar
wood
and john cocker who produced this
built-up area of buildings
that is unique in the united kingdom
we are caretakers of the conservation
area which we should be preserving for
future generations
thank you very much for letting me speak
thank you councillor mrs young um i
cannot see
any members as having indicated they'd
like to open
i i i thought there was um there is
somebody speaking in favor sorry
mr tom bedford are you on the call mr
pepper
yes yes yeah i
speak um apologize as as with the
previous speakers if you run over time
i'll just
lightly request that you wrap up thank
you okay thanks very much chair
um my client is relocating back to hale
uh with a growing family and the very
close family relations are now will now
need to travel significant
distances to visit therefore the
additional space is required
to continue living in their family home
and accommodate their visiting family
members
we have worked closely with the case
officer to address all concerns through
detailed changes
to develop the scheme which the case
obviously and the principal planning
officer are now supporting and
recommending for approval
inspiration was taken from the
architectural style of the existing
house and the wider conservation area
using high quality materials
architectural features and detailing
to sympathetically integrate the
proposal the conservation officer
welcomed these changes yet raises some
concerns about the impact
on the greater listed building and
conservation area using the previously
refused scheme
to support her comments they do not
recognize the extent of the changes from
the refused application
nor do they refer to the secluded
position of the proposal
the inspector at the time raised no
concerns on the impact of the nearby
listed buildings
therefore these objections are
disproportionate to the small decrease
in space between the single-story side
extension
and the side boundary when comparing the
existing dwelling and the proposal
with reference to the case office report
the proposal is considered to respect
its setting and would preserve and not
cause any harm to the spatial character
appearance or significance of the spec
of the south hale conservation area
alongside the setting of the adjacent
grade two listed buildings
proposed garage extinction is smaller
and sympathetically designed
by maintaining existing eaves and bridge
heights the side
extension is predominantly single story
maintaining a similar distance to the
boundary
as the existing garage with a two-story
element further away again
this in itself is notably different to
the refused application
which had the full two-story side
extension within 2.4 meters of the
boundary
south hill spg has now been superseded
and there is no
now no reference to the distance between
boundaries in which the previous
application was determined
it is the council's view that the
sighting and scale of the side extension
is considered
acceptable in preserving the spacious
character of the conservation area
referring back to the case officer
reports again the concerns raised by the
raised by the council and planning
inspector at the time regarding
spaciousness and the character of the
area are considered to have been
overcome through the present design
the proposal is considered to be of a
high quality design and proportionate in
scale and mass
of the existing citing sitting
comfortably within the plots with
sufficient space to boundaries and
overall scale reflecting
reflective of the surrounding properties
therefore it does not constitute over
development
although the built form is close to the
boundary the properties of long-range
avenues sufficient facing distances will
still be provided
the step design of the side extension
varied roof scape
drop in ridge heights and hipped roof
design avoids any overbearing impact
and unreasonable visual intrusion on
their immunities
windows along this elevation are to be
obscurely glazed to protect privacy
and reduce any potential overlooking
there will be no objections from
highways agricultural consulties or
landscaping with regards to this
application
to conclude i would like to refer back
to the case officer's report it is
considered
that there are no adverse impacts that
would significantly or demonstrably
outweigh the benefits of granting
permission hopefully through working
closely and productively with the case
officer to produce a high quality and
well-designed scheme
which respects preserves and enhances
the south hill conservation area
the recommended approval can be
supported many thanks
thank you mr bedford um i think
in the chat the council accordingly
you've indicated you'd like to open the
debate
ah thank you chair um yeah i like i'd
like to propose
accepting the officer's recommendation
on this
i've been to see the site i was lucky
enough to get in via
the occupants of 231a um
and the distance between this property
and the neighboring properties
is spacious it is spacious i
i don't i i think we're overblowing this
um it's going to remain spacious after
the development
i'm quite happy to support the proposal
it brings it back into use
um the the family who let me in were
very supportive and they're the nearest
neighbours
um so i i i see no
i think the planners have worked hard to
get this to approve and not
have an impact on the listed buildings
which is the most important
uh aspect um but i think they've worked
through that
and i think they've ended up with a good
proposal and i'm happy to propose
support thank you council accordingly
and councillor morgan
indicated in the chess thanks chef
um i'll be brief um i can't particularly
say i
physically like this development i think
it's a real it is a very big
massive development um but i think it is
and i do know the heritage officer's
comments which i know i've said on a
previous
um application
but i do think it's worth noting that
the only
those who've made their opposition in
the comments
on the planning portal um are all on
grange
um avenue and they aren't in the south
hale conservation area um it's just
this plot and those to the to the
previous plot um i'm not entirely sure
the original application but i don't
actually think i do i'm going to agree
with the council accordingly i don't
think it
i don't think it makes any um negative
impact on the
south hill conservation era so i think i
will probably be supporting officer
recommendations tonight thank you
thank you councillor morgan um any other
members looking to contribute to the
discussion
no and well i suppose i find myself
largely in agreement with council
accordingly i think
the key point for me is that actually
that the plots here that they're sizable
and they're capable of accommodating an
extension
and you know when you look at the
pictures of the gardens and the
surrounding area it's clear that
the the developments and displays can be
um
almost camouflaged or mitigated for
because of the foliage and because of
the trees present
and i think critically again similarly
to the last application it's a question
of balance isn't it
about whether or not the harm is so
extensive that it won't be reasonable
um to grant the permission i think in in
this instance i
i think i i don't see there has been
such
a substantial harm to heritage with the
character of the conservation area that
couldn't approve this so as a
consequence i'm happy
to second uh council according lee's
proposal
that we approve the application this
evening
um are there any members will a burning
desire to contribute
before we move to a vote i know can i
speak
yeah i i did say in the chat but
just before mike calling me but i think
you might miss me but
not no problem um
yeah i i think it is a a tough one here
and i do think it's finally balanced
again and similar to the last
application but um i would to take into
account what the heritage officer
has said and i know that's been repeated
already but he does say it would erode
the spacious character and appearance of
the
south hill conservation area and i
thought the arguments put forward by
councillor
young and um the resident speaking
against were quite compelling um and i
i thought i think there is an impact on
heritage and immunity so
i would disagree um and i think
um counseling young also mentioned a
cumulative impact
um and when you do keep kind of chipping
away at
a conservation area i think it it can
kind of amount to over time uh
you know an impact um so
i think i'd probably it's a tough
decision but i probably will be voting
against officer recommendation again
thanks chair thank you council jerome
apologies for not clocking that you'd
indicated that
um are there any other members looking
to contribute to the discussion
no but the application has now been
proposed and seconded that we
approve permission in line with office
of recommendations so i'll
cycle through members as you appear on
the screen and ask you to verbally
confirm how you're voting
and counselling yes i support
thank you councillor councillor jerome
thank you councillor councillor thomas i
support you
thank you councillor councillor winston
uh mr approving live lost his
recommendation
thank you councillor councillor minis
uh and thank you um i can't see a real
reason to object so i'll be um
in support of officer recommendation
thank you thank you
councillor councillor proctor
relation to grant so can you just repeat
that i missed the start there so we go
support cancer accordingly
sorry about that i support i suddenly
couldn't get the mute button
thank you counselor counselor morgan uh
thank you chair
um like councilmembers can't see a
reason to oppose our uh
sporting officer recommendations thank
you councillor councillor holden
i would support the officer's
recommendations
and i will be voting in favor of officer
recommendations so
i think that's nine to one um
consequently
that permission has been granted this
evening and
thank you for those people who turned up
to
contribute to the discussion um the next
application that we
will be determining is great stone hotel
which is on page 139 of your committee
reports
um and there will be an officer
introduction from
mr pearson thank you chairman if you
could just play with me for a sec whilst
i
try and share my screen
can everybody see the uh the site plan
on the screen
okay um this application relates to
the science of great stone hotel in
stratford there are two existing
buildings on the eastern side of chester
road one of which is used as a hotel
the other is ancillary residential
accommodation
so you can see the two buildings here
outline planning permission is sought
for the demolition of
the two buildings and their replacement
with a part by part
four-storey l-shaped residential
apartment building
to provide 56 apartments 10 percent of
which would be affordable
approvally sought for all matters other
than the appearance and landscape
which are reserved the application is
reported to committee because
more than six representations contrary
to officer recommendation
have been received so just talking
through the the scheme
very brief briefly what you can see here
is a
single building covering most of the
site
the vehicular access is from from this
point here where my cursor is
um with a little bit of landscaping to
the front
um but then the access road runs all the
way down the
side of the building around to a car
park which
covers the remaining part of the site
um so that's the um that's the ground
floor
uh layout there
let's move on to the elevations um what
we see here
um is the entrance lodge and portal to
uh and then to the right of it
the building as as amended as reduced in
height
so five stories across pretty much the
full width of the site
rather than allowing for slight access
to the right of the building
and then the the view that you see up
here
um is taken from the rear so there you
see
a kind of abstract way the the rear of
the entrance portal
um this bit being the return leg of the
building so the the element that runs
alongside the
entrance path to the park and then the
taller element behind it
the the bit that um fronts fronts to the
main road
and in here of course
and there just the other elevations so
that's the elevation to
the entrance to the park along the path
of the park
and that's the return side elevation
if you were to look at it from the
social club on
on the side of the site um
just one other image there which is
taken from inside the park
which illustrates that in whilst in some
of us the trees provide the reason it's
green to the site
in in windsor the spike is very much
open to view and and has
quite an impact on the setting of the
not just the part but the
launches as well so
at certainly in the officer port
um we have no objection in principle to
the redevelopment of this site
but we consider the specific application
to be unacceptable for a number of
reasons
as i said the proposal seeks permission
for a large l-shaped single building
which is rather monolithic in character
we consider the form of the development
to be inappropriate and out of character
with the urban grain of the area
which is characterized by much smaller
residential buildings of lower height
officers are constrained extremely
concerned about the height scale mass
and sighting of the development
which is considered to represent
quarters behind by
dominating an adverse impact on the
adjacent park
buildings as well as the area generally
the site will be dominated by the
building parking area and access road
though space available available for any
meaningful high quality
community space at ground level
unlimited space for lost scan lot for
landscaping
due to the cramped over developed nature
of the site
this would result in a poor standard of
immunity for future residents
we believe which would be exacerbated by
the failure of most of the apartments to
meet the nationally described space
standard
as i mentioned before the site sits
adjacent to the great enlisted
gauze hill park entrance portable lodges
great stone
and stratford war memorial across the
a56 which is also greatly listed
the development is considered to cause
major harm to the entrance portal of
watches
moderate harm to the war memory
in mppf terms this is considered to
equate to less than substantial harm to
the significance of the list of
buildings
this home is not considered to be
outweighed by the public benefits of
proposals
major benefits are seen as additional
residential units
and the 10 affordable housing
however it is considered that such
benefits could also be delivered by a
more
appropriately designed scheme that sat
more comfortably with its arrangements
despite requests for the applicant
insufficient justification has been
provided to adequately demonstrate that
the level of parking provision
will be sufficient to accommodate demand
arising
from the proposed development and that
would not result in harm to residential
immunity through
overspill parking within the surrounding
area
there are 56 apartments proposed on site
and 23 parsley
as the development is specifically
restricted by a paragraph
11d1 of the mppf due to the heritage
impacts
the tilted balance does not apply in
this case as it does for many
residential levels
and for the reasons the other reasons
i've identified the application is
recommended for refusal thank you sean
i'll take the screen down
thank you mr pearson um i understand
there's nobody speaking against
the application um but there is somebody
speaking in favor of an overturn of
officer recommendation
uh to approve the application mr heinz
hello chair hi mr heinz um you have
three minutes to speak and if you're
everyone i'll just politely request that
your
life will be remarked thank you thank
you hello committee
the proposal is to redevelop the hotel
the site is a suitable
brownfield site for redevelopment so
every unit that developed here
will mean one unit less on a greenfield
site
demolition is acceptable as is
redevelopment for housing
in short it is a site where
redevelopment should be supported in
principle
the site is in a sustainable location
close to local amenities
as well as being well served by public
transport plus services along the a-56
and a metrolink nearby there is no
objection from the local highway
authority
the proposal is to provide 56 apartments
in a modest height building of five
stories from the a56
and four stories to the rear the roof
terrace
provides for external amenity space for
all occupiers
whilst the vast majority of apartments
benefit from private balconies
the design has taken account of the
immediate surroundings
including the nearby listed buildings
and gauce hill park
the surroundings contain large
commercial buildings including tesco
various car showrooms and trafford house
at 12 stores high
the development covers 36 of the site's
area
the proposed scale compares well with
the range of development suggestions set
out in the emerging area action plan
for the civic quarter and the recently
built out nova scheme
the scheme before you has been amended
several times since the pre-application
proposal in 2018
reducing the height of both parts of the
building as well as the number of
apartments proposed
the proposal has however been carefully
designed by leading architects
and is a bespoke scheme the objections
to design relate to height and massing
but the height of the five story
frontage is 87 centimeters higher
than the height of early chords opposite
the side boundary runs alongside the
path leading from the a56 to the park
it's worth noting that the path is
little used as evidenced by the
vandalized states of the gates
themselves
most pedestrians enter the power by one
of three other access points
with regard to the wider impact of the
proposal on the listed buildings
it is agreed that the impact will be low
the new building will be further away
from the gates than is the existing
building
and we believe will improve the setting
of those gates
the proposal will not overlook the main
areas of the park
users of the playing pictures to the
rear will be some distance away
the park is in an event surrounded by
development
the consultation sorry the application
has received 12 comments from members of
the public
nine of which are local to the area and
of which only two object
there is generally local support
benefits
the proposal efficiently reuses a
brownfield site
for which there are no objections on the
grounds of noise
air quality flood risk arbor culture
ecology
access servicing or highway safety
the proposal delivers affordable housing
as the development will comply with
policy
the proposal makes efficient use of an
urban site
and delivers much needed housing itself
we consider a significant
and demonstrable public benefit if
planning permission is granted
we suggest a planning agreement is
entered into to secure
off-site landscaping at the boundary of
the site with the park
as well as at the war memorial as well
as affordable housing
in numbers to comply with policy chair
and committee thank you for the
opportunity to speak
thank you mr hein um a number of members
have indicated they'd like to
contribute to the discussion council
accordingly you can
hear man sorry yeah
this depends on you indicated yes sorry
actually i posted a note in the chat but
it was rather like
um yeah i just really wanted to to come
back really on a number of points that
mr
haines has raised i think it's quite
important to do so
now uh a number of the points that he
raised um
are covered in the letter that he
submitted to members and officers
earlier in the week
um and those are covered in
additional information reports so you
can see those
pages
but i think it's important also to cover
a
number of other points um both
both that were in the letter and that mr
hines has just raised in his
address to commit suggesting that the
applicant has worked
proactively with planning officers to
ensure that they address our concerns
um most recently they suggest by
reducing the height of the
proposal by a single story is really not
true i'm afraid
um officers have provided clear advice
at pre-application stage and raised
concerns i mean
mr heinz suggested our design concerns
relate to
height and massing that's a very
simplistic view of the case that's
that's really not the case our concerns
relate to
form first and foremost the fact that
this is a single
large building on this site but not just
for scale mass layout
and the advice that we gave both the
pre-application
stage and when the application came in
has been largely disregarded
i mean the last thing as i've just
touched on it refers to
objections from the council between
subjective matters of design
these are not subjective matters the the
mppf is clear that the creation of high
quality buildings and places is
fundamental to what the planning and
development process should achieve
the fact that we have a lack of a
five-year housing land supply
should not mean development at any cost
for the suggestion that
this is a brownfield site so any any
development that you
achieve on this site is a greenfield
site saved it is
an argument that's simply too simplistic
um
so there are a number of other issues um
so we've set out our concerns about
design in the
in the reports we've updated those in
the additional information reports
i mean the reference to to burley court
across the road being of
the same height the early courts is a
reasonably tall building although
its design is very different for this
one but the mouth of burleigh court is a
fraction
of the mass that would result from from
this development because of the width of
it
because of the depth of it in relation
to
matters of heritage um
these are set out in the commissary
courts reports and they're obviously
categorized as
less than substantial uh harms required
by
the mppf but we do again as
as recommended in the ppf or the ppg we
do
set out what that level of harm is and
that's articulated
as a major harm at the upper end of that
scale
in relation to the lodging gates
now mr hines has suggested that the home
identifier to the heritage assets is
solely to the asset
setting not direct harm to the
assets at all so again this is
this is a worrying thing to say because
assets may be affected by you know
physical changes to the building
or by the change in their setting
enhance for the setting of the listed
building is still harmed to its
significance
the planning act and acts and the mppf
don't differentiate the weight to be
given to an impactful listed
setting to give less weight to a
harmful impact because it is to setting
itself
would be unlawful
mr hines is also suggests that um the
mppf
requires us to be clear reasons for
refusing the development on
heritage grounds um and that given the
less than substantial harm
that's identified the tilted balance
should not be engaged
but again the mppf is very clear that
great weight
should be given to an aspects
conservation irrespective
of whether any potential harm amounts to
substantial harm
total loss or less than substantial harm
to significance
so again this assessment appropriately
set out in report
um again it would be unlawful to
conclude that lessons substantial harm
means that the tilted balance is not
engaged
in terms of the parking issues uh mr
heinz said that the local highway
authority didn't object to the proposal
the local highway authority are
concerned about the proposal because
they don't feel
sufficient justification has been
provided for the level of parking
uh proposed um and to suggest that that
matter could be conditioned again would
be inappropriate
because those matters really need to be
considered during the consideration of
the application
uh just one final point um
a couple of final points in relation to
the the the impact on managing future
residents again i think
the suggestion for mr heinz is that our
concern relates
to a lack of immunity space that is the
case we do because
we are concerned about immunity space
but it's also about the poorest the
general poor standard of immunity for
future residents
and the fact that these these apartments
don't meet the national space standard
and it's very one final point in
relation to the heads of terms that were
put to members of the letter um
a number of those points points two
three and four relating to landscaping
spotlights and birds are matters which
should commit to be met
minded to approve the application or
things that should be dealt with by
condition
was the final one the fixtures and
fittings from the great stone hotel
it's just not a planning matter at all
thank you chairman
sorry that that took some time all right
thank you mr pearson and council i've
been uh
answered the court in the indicated
letter
uh thank you chair uh this is in my ward
so i think i'm
probably right to speak first um
yeah i'm not going to blur the issue
particularly because i think
um david pearson's put a lot of the view
a lot of the reasons for a refusal there
i do support refusal
i don't think this is the right
development
i hope they can come back and come back
with a better one
because although i rather like the great
stone hotel
i do acknowledge it's reached the end of
his life
um
so the the the in terms of the massing
the uh the size the impact on listed
buildings all the things that
um mr pearce has mentioned i think we
should back the um
refusal on this one and uh totally
support the refusal
propose that we accept it thank you
councillor and
councillor jerome thanks joe
i won't talk too long either that's not
to repeat other people
i agree with the council accordingly and
happy to second
second him on on um supporting off the
recommendation
um i'll just do
so um
i think mr pearson
describes everything really and i would
also
look at the heritage and and agree with
refusal on that i mean paragraph 96 i
think is very compelling
um that the proposed development
represents a poor design
that's in this especially in this
location on scale massing
and sighting um and it would have an
adverse impact on gorsil park i think
which was clear
in the introduction um but i thought i
went to
onto a historic england uh website just
to have a look at the gates
and on on that website it tells us the
gates at
to the park are mid 19th century they
were the original gangster trafford hall
so i think in indian heritage terms
there's some of the most important
heritage
in the borough you know trafford hall no
longer exists but the
the lake still it exists at the ecology
park and the gates that
that um that hall exist at the park
so they are of the highest significance
and i think uh
this building does have an impact um on
those gates
and you know there's many compelling um
arguments for uh this building on
brownfield site
you know there is it meets is compliant
with affordable housing
i do think the heritage impact is just
too high
and i will be supporting um the officer
recommendation to refuse
thanksgiving thank you councillor jerome
councillor win stanley
uh thank you yeah i'll also be
supporting the officer recommendation i
was a bit disappointed with this because
unlike council accordingly i don't like
the great stone hotel at all
and every time i drive up chester road
or take me like in the hands and cycle
of chester road
it is a real life saw and i was a bit
disappointed that the
i'm happy that it would be demolished
but the the building to be replaced that
that
was scheduled to be uh was being
considered tonight
is wrong for all the reasons we that's
councillors accordingly and jerome have
gone through and have been
uh well summed up by uh mr pearson so i
will be
um voting to refuse this
uh before i finish and just make a note
of shout out to the officers because i'm
really pleased
in this application and there's a whole
section on equalities
89 to 93 which is fantastic i feel some
step change in the way that we consider
um in the way that we consider
uh planning applications um
though i would i would just to say
another thing on that
in the in the paragraph 93 we're talking
about no dis benefits
in terms of equalities and i think we
could be stronger than that in our
relationships with developers
and we should be talking about waste
generating
um benefits under the equality section
not a
section for a very big debate tonight
but just to to note that
thank you chair thank you councillor and
councillor proctor
uh thank you chair yeah i concur with
what
has been said so far um i think that
obviously the heritage issue is a
is a problem and also the the impact on
the
the park i think it will have a
not significant but it will have an
impact on
on the visual immunity in the park so
that there's two big issues
but for me the major one is the
the currently parking issue i mean
currently
the greatest timetable you've got um 24
rooms this is 56
apartments um
and very very limited car parking spaces
23.
it is a good mix you know there's some
disabled park spaces motorcycle spaces
and actual vehicle charging points um
and quite a lot of backspaces so that's
that's good but overall i think it would
be an issue um much
emphasis has been made in the report
about the public transport
facilities nearby and yes there's a good
bus route
on the a56 right next to it but you look
at the
the metro link it's quite a distance
away so i don't think that is
particularly significant so i think this
this current
you know plan would be a major problem
for the area in in terms of car parking
so that's my particular emphasis
obviously you know we want to see ground
fuel sites
uh established and the housing would be
an important benefit to to traffic
but i think the the negative aspects of
this
application are too severe for us to
approve it and i will be voting with the
along with the officer recommendation to
refuse
thank you chair thank you councillor i'm
councillor minister
thank you chair um yeah i i've i've
i was really really excited to see
obviously brownfield site
uh being vote but obviously
the proposed um idea
is there's a number of issues isn't it
there's a number of obviously
the size of it how it then dwarfs things
that are
clearly of um important um heritage
you know concerns for us and we want to
have those assets there
and and that we can see those and i mean
it's not massive there's not a big
block building to effectively dwarf it
and
there's also i'd like something to come
i would like it develop though i would
like it to be developed but something
far more suitable and i also want people
to think about
you know where provisions of yes housing
but also
where you know school places would be
so that we can have um something that's
much more suitable we've got 56
dwellings there where people are going
to go to school et cetera
lots of lots of things to to you know
say i'm not fan of
and so i'll be supporting the officer's
recommended
recommendations for just to refuse thank
you
thank you councilman minis and
councillor hartley
thank you chair uh like other members
i'll be supporting the officer
recommendation to
to refuse the application um i agree
with what most of what's been said and
i'll try not to
repeat that um the the current site and
i probably agree with councillor win
stanley i think that um
you know the current site or certainly
the buildings on the site are quite
dilapidated and they are a bit of an
eyesore and have been for some time
so i would like to see the site
developed uh
you know so in principle fine to
demolish those buildings and to develop
the site
and in principle you know i'd probably
accept that the development that that
will occur there is likely to be
like to be residential and likely to be
apartments
but i think as the report it concludes
really the fact that there is
a housing shortage in traffic and that
we need to
build dwellings and that we need to
build on brownfield land
doesn't mean we uh you know we can throw
up poor quality
uh housing and i think that's what this
is to be honest the
the development is is overly dominant uh
you know the massing is too great
i can see that it would be perfectly
possible to to develop that site and and
have a a building with you know a
smaller mass further
further back from the from the front of
the site which would
um you know uh mitigate some of the
impact on the on the heritage
uh assets that are in that area and if
you go to the area
you you can see that there's a there's a
you know there's a sense of like a
circle or a semi-circular opening you
know sort of clearing there where the
heritage
assets are placed and and this this
would interfere with that so i
you know i do agree that there is you
know major uh
if less than substantial harm to those
to those heritage
assets and you know we should be looking
to
to enhance those assets uh not just
preserve them as they are and not be
making them worse and again that would
be possible i think with the development
here but this
this proposal uh doesn't doesn't do that
um
the design is poor i know the i know the
appearance is a reserved uh
matter but i think the design of the
scheme in terms of
size of the apartments which which are
small below the national
space standards and also the lack of
immunity space
um i think this makes this a you know a
poor design so
you know i'll do we do need housing um
and we do need to develop brownfield
sites
we can we can do better than this uh and
and people
uh coming to live in trafford you know
we have a big variety of housing
but you know we need to ensure we have
uh good quality uh good quality design
good quality development
and and that people are accommodated in
in in good quality
uh dwellings you know whatever they're
whatever that means so
for those reasons i'll be supporting the
officer recommendation to
to refuse thank you chair thank you
council hartley and councilman morgan
thank you chair uh be very brief um i
want to see the totally agree whether i
heard council accordingly um at the
start um in terms of his reason why
he'll be supporting officer
recommendations to refuse
and i originally read this and we
presumed that we were
granting it and um quite pleased when i
saw the office of recommendations
um towards the end um yeah i mean
mr pearson said exactly this isn't just
we're just predicted this isn't just
been the planning offices
on a mere technicality this is um
there's really substantive reasons why
um and i mean i actually quite like the
view of the hotel
if it could be saved it probably can't
but
we do need better applications than this
and um on
such an important part of our borough in
such a prominent location
on chester road so yeah i'll be running
we'll offer recommendations to reviews
thank you
thank you councillor morgan and
councillor rigby your hand is up i think
yes um i'll put it down because
councillor hartley has been reading my
script
he said exactly what i was going to say
and i'll be supporting the officer's
recommendations
thank you councillor i mean i i think it
appears that the
opinion of um committee is pretty
unanimous on this now
um i i would just say myself that i i
was really quite disappointed
the further i got into um scrutinizing
this application
uh given all of the remarks i've made at
planning committees previously
i was expecting to be enthusiastic about
an application on a brownfield site that
would deliver
a policy compliant level of affordable
housing
but as you start to troll through the
committee report and it's an extremely
robust report because
it touches on every single aspect of
failing
uh with this application you realize
that
you simply cannot support this one of
the things that
left out with me and it was a tiny
detail was the fact that
officers have assessed that the
balconies included
on some of the flats are so tiny in size
that they're practically unfit for use
and you know not only um
do some of the flats fall beneath uh the
proposed
uh the acceptable space standard for new
developments they fall
wildly below yeah and i i i say that as
somebody who thinks that the uh
agreeable space standard for new
developments is too small as it stands
so i'm not going to be supporting this
application i think it's in a location
that is of civic importance to trafford
and
civic importance to stratford and i just
have this vision of a great big huge
block
of flats sat on top of our war memorial
and i don't think that's an acceptable
way
um to honor that site so um it has been
proposed and seconded that we vote in
line with officer recommendation to
refuse this application
and i'll now move on to the vote um
councillor jerome if you can confirm
how you're voting this evening
it's a recommendation to review thanks
chair
thank you councillor councillor thomas
i'll support the recommendation to
refuse it
thank you councillor councillor win
stanley uh thank you chair voting live
with officer recommendation to refuse
thank you councillor councillor minis
um i'm supporting the officer
recommendation to refuse thank you
thank you councillor councillor proctor
proctor
force officer recommendation to refuse
thank you chair thank you councillor
councillor hartley
thank you chair support officer
recommendation to reviews thank you
councillor councillors accordingly
still support officer recommendation to
refuse
thank you councillor councillor rigby
support the
officer's recommendation to refuse thank
you
councillor councillor morgan uh sport
officer recommendation to refuse chair
thank you how's the councillor hold it
support
the officer's recommendation to refuse
thank you council and i will be voting
to support officer recommendation to
refuse
and i make that a unanimous refusal of
the application
thank you and the next application
that we're turning to is chesham house
which is on page 139 of your committee
report
and before we hear from uh
representatives we've got
an officer introduction from mr pearson
sorry chairman it's myself um he'll be
presenting this one just
just that's fine just bear with me while
i share my screen
can everybody say that excellent
okay um this this is cheshire house on
church road in erneston
and uh members will recall that earlier
in the autumn this site
came before the planning committee for
the authorisation for the service but
article 4 direction to prevent the
demolition of the property
there have been a number of applications
for demolition
which also proposed the replacement of
the existing properties with two
new semi-detached properties members at
that meeting resolved unanimously that
the article four direction should be
served and with immediate effects and
that and that took place
um the uh site owner's response to this
has been
um has been to propose the retention of
the property
um so this application doesn't propose
its demolition
uh but instead it's it's the extension
to enable its subdivision into two
semi-detached dwellings
the application is reported to committee
because there have been six or more
objections received
contrary to the officer recommendation
the key issues here are the impact on
undesignated heritage assets design and
residential amenity
officers consider that this particular
proposal would have a negligible degree
of harm on the heritage grounds uh
associated with the extension
subdivision of the the building uh the
fact that the building has been
is being retained in this scheme is a
significant benefit uh the fact that it
needs to be extended in order to do that
um that that is considered on balance to
be a
a neutral impact uh and and the benefits
of keeping it are obviously positive
um and in the viable use there's also
benefits
in respect of the provision of new
housing
uh the impact of the proposals on
residential emergency the neighbouring
properties
and its parking impacts have already
been all also been considered and
considered to be acceptable
and therefore the application is
recommended for approval
thank you thank you
ms cody um we have got statements i
think um
against and for the application um a
statement from
mr alexander against the applications up
being read out
yes um mr day and ms lowe's are going to
read one out
each i can't recall which who's doing
which one at the
present but whoever's doing the one to
they can
sort that out yeah i'm going to read the
objection yeah is that is that the one
you want next
uh please mr d thank you yes so it's um
an objection from john alexander um
i object to the proposals for chesham
house on the grounds that they
constitute a loss of amenity
such large detached properties have been
important
in the development of the urban district
from its inception
providing premises for various health
officers and clinics
as well as district council officers
moorfields earnston
and collingwood davy him they've also
proved essential in the setting up
of rest homes nurseries surgeries
offices and social clubs throughout the
area
chesham house is a prime example of such
multi-purpose
use having been a family hotel
and before that a starter home for
abbotsfield school
i list these facts to illustrate the
point that such properties are not
the white elephants they claim to be by
the developers but can play
an essential role in the local economy
my argument is that by making another of
these convertibles
i.e properties that have the potential
for numerous uses
into yet another semi-detached house it
not only reduces the variety of the
local housing stock
but also limits the scope such buildings
offer to business startups
they've already been seriously depleted
it is about time that properties such as
chesham house
are recognized as having intrinsic value
beyond that of the land in which they
stand
they are soundly built and will outlast
many more recent developments
there is nothing in the area
sorry there is nothing in the area that
can replace them the bulk our pre and
post-war properties lack the capacity
for change
no one will be able to set up a small
hotel or a day nursery
in a three bed semi indeed many such
houses are already proving unsuitable
for present day living
all across the districts housings
householders are having add-ons
cramming another bedroom into a roof
space making a garage into a living room
erecting an office in the garden it is
ironic that in light of such
developments
it should be deemed necessary for a
viable residence to be reduced in size
albeit gaining two for the price of one
these proposals also come at a time when
there's a recognition that work
and living patterns are changing
radically there is
a discernible move towards people
working from home
and it is anticipated that this will
become the norm in the years ahead
along with this there is a rise in three
generational households
also requiring larger houses so there is
little doubt that
properties such as chesham house will be
in which will be much needed in the
district
should a split in the property be agreed
it should be made on the proviso that it
can be made reversible
thank you
thank you mr day uh mrs lowes
hi yes i'll be reading a statement
from a mr kevin coogan i'm making this
submission
on behalf of my wife britisha coogan the
applicant
the proposal is actually a family
venture we have pooled our resources to
undertake this development
the proposal is to provide two good
family homes
one to which my wife and i will retire
along with our adult son who has down
syndrome
the other house will be for our
daughter's family our daughter and
family have lived in amsterdam for over
15 years
she owns a child nursery in the trafford
area giving employment to around 40
people
as you are probably aware cheshium house
has not been a residence for over 80
years
throughout this time it has been in
commercial use fiercely as a building in
education use
and more recently as a guest house when
we investigated this building there was
no way of telling that it was a
non-designated asset
in fact this was not raised as an issue
until after we purchased and we were
well into the planning
process nevertheless that being the case
we prepared an alternative scheme to
embrace the council's wish to have the
building retained
it is this scheme which is before you
now
i'm not sure if you've been around the
building understandably difficult in the
current time
the rear of the building is in is in a
poor state with old stock brick
showing its age along with the mish mash
of substandard windows and lean-to's
internally the building has suffered
throughout its years in commercial use
very little of the original features
exist
internal subdivisions abound moreover
the original fabric and structure is in
extreme need of attention
defects range from defective roof
structure defective floors propped up
with makeshift supports
damp ingress poor and effective windows
and substantial presence of asbestos
the wiring and plumbing services are
also well past their sell by
all in all a well hacked about building
crying out for a sympathetic conversion
we engaged a local award-winning
designer he has worked closely with mr
wiseman
between them they have produced a most
sympathetic scheme
to convey it from commercial to family
living while not detracting from the
character of the original building
i myself am a retired architect and
intend one of these houses to be our
forever home
so clearly i have the know-how and a
vested interest in ensuring the
restoration to a very high standard
we have made contact with our immediate
neighbors who have been most welcoming
and supportive there have been no
concerns regarding our scheme having a
negative impact upon them
in fact they are very they very much
want to see the building back in family
use
subject to approval we intend to appoint
a local reputable contractor
to undertake the scheme in one bite thus
minimising disruption drawing building
works in light of the above i therefore
respectfully request
that the council looks favorably on this
application
thank you kevin coogan on behalf of the
applicant
thank you ms lowe's and councillor
jerome i think you've indicated happy to
open the discussion
we know that previous applications have
suggested demolishing this building
but most people would recognize this
building as a great feature and asset to
the area and it would be tragic if it
was lost
um this application retains this
building brings it back into life as a
residential dwelling
and i think significantly retains its
character
and you know we have to remember that
the tilted balance applies here
and this will make two dwellings
contributing to land supply targets in
in a sustainable location
um within an established residential
area i also like the fact that they're
keeping um garden space
180 square meters garden space so it's
compliant with pg-1
um and i also like some of the design
features i think they're they're being
true to
the original materials and i'm pleased
that wooden frame windows are being used
and they're also using matching slate so
i think the feel of the building will be
kept cosmetic cosmetically we're also
following the recommendations of the bat
survey which is uh fantastic
um and i do accept some of the arguments
against i mean there will be some harm
caused to the street scene which i think
is outlined in the report but i think
overall
um i'm in favor of um supporting offer
officer recommendation here and i'm
happy to propose it
so thanks joe thank you councillor and
councillor proctor yeah thank you chair
i
very much agree with what council jerome
has just said actually
um it's in my ward so i've got a kind of
uh increased interest in this
application and this is a very
uh attractive exterior building and
i wouldn't want anything to be done to
to that which would
cause a detrimental effect and
looking at the plans i think they're
really really good and i don't think
they're gonna
have a have a detrimental effect at all
um i think it's very
very can be done very tastefully and i
think uh
it's gonna retain his historical form
and um they've obviously you're gonna be
using
good good materials which will help in
terms of that retaining of character
so i think they've come up with some
really really
good plans and i'm quite reassured by
what mr kugma was saying
previously you know i did have some
concerns that it might not be
done in a way which would enhance
treasure house
but i think that's that's really
reassured me quite considerably
will it have some harm on the uh church
church street scene yes but that's quite
quite limited and it's not going to be
significant and i think overall
the benefits of this are going to be
much
much greater than the negative aspects
um so on balance
i i'm going to be supporting the officer
recommendation to agree
and i'm looking forward to seeing what
the fight finished product will be in
the future
thank you chair thank you councillor
councillor hartley
thank you chair yeah i'll also be um
sporting office right recommendation to
to grant um you know it's it
is a beautiful building of its time and
um
having having previously authorized the
the article
article four directions so the house
couldn't be demolished um
you know i do think i do think we have a
responsibility
to ensure that that that that
heritage asset yeah gets preserved so
that's not to say we should just approve
any application to to develop it but
um you know the longer the building
stands empty the more dilapidated it
will get and and then effectively where
you know we're not preserving the asset
so i think i think this this proposal
the development has proposed is
is is quite good it preserves the
building um
the development does cause some harm to
the to the heritage of that
of that building um for me looking at
the elevations
it's mainly it's meant that the first
floor extension over the
over sort of what was the billiard room
smoking room um
you know i accept it's it's got to be
developed really in
in that sort of a way um
and but the render just doesn't doesn't
look quite right um
but you know i i know there's comments
in the report that
um they couldn't find um you know
matching bricks etc so i think that's i
think that's okay i think i think the
new front door
doesn't look too bad actually i think
that blends in quite well so i think you
know there is some harm there
i think it's it's minor negligible harm
and the benefits of the
of the scheme in particular the benefit
of
of preserving the asset uh as a heritage
asset i
i think you know outweigh that legible
harm and um yeah i mean i was also
struck by what
mr coogan said actually that it hadn't
been used as a house for 80 years
and um and also what he said about the
current state of the
of the building uh which has been empty
for a while i think so
you know this is a good proposal because
it it develops the
property and preserves it as two new
dwellings whereas i feel
ever if a commercial use um was
was secure for the building then that's
probably less likely to
to preserve the heritage of the building
so
yeah i'm broadly supportive i think i
think the um
the report um strikes the right balance
i think the benefits do clearly outweigh
any harm to to the heritage asset so
i'll be voting uh in favor of the
officer recommendation chair thank you
thank you councillor
councillor stanley yeah thank you jay i
continue with continuing the theme so
i'll
try and be brief i love church road i
love the way it looks now if i could set
an aspect i'd do that but we can't
and this development strikes are um i
think strokes are a really
sympathetic balance between the house
the
houses exist now and a modern take on
the house
um and i read with great interest the
the kind of materials
which would be used in the redevelopment
are going to be extremely sympathetic to
the
existing structure and i think well um i
don't think they will actually damage
the aspect of church right i think a lot
to it
so very much in favor of this
development as well in line with officer
recommendation thank you
thank you councillor winston the
councillor thomas
thank you uh yeah the old keys house
school is quite a um
well-known building down church road and
i visited the site i've looked at it and
i can't see
where although there will be negligible
and
heritage impact i i certainly believe as
with
uh councilman stanley just now that
this remodeling
renewing of the property can only be a
benefit to
church road so i will be supporting
the recommendation to graham thank you
councillor
council the minutes i think you
indicated that you had a question you'd
like to ask
um yes thank you it's about really like
the matching i get i get the
obviously the building's not been in use
for for a number of years
and i'm really i like the idea of
bringing it back into you so like the
idea of having
sympathetic sort of respiration and bit
of conversion done so that it can
actually be
used and to brought into housing in
already residential area
my question is really about the um the
trying to match um
materials and obviously this is
as um as has been commented on
in in report about the rendering and
things is there a reason why we can't
match i know it may not match the exact
materials obviously because it's an old
building but
in terms of color and things like that
and sort of what's in appearance why we
can't match it that's that was my
question
um it's difficult to find
a precise match for historic bricks um
because it isn't just the materials it's
also the weathering
um so they don't they don't necessarily
weather in the
in the same way so you can get reclaimed
bricks but if they've been on a
different elevation then they will have
weathered
differently sometimes this is better not
to and if you try and match
very good bricks very good historic
bricks with a
modern brick it is more obtrusive than
using a different
uh traditional material and rendering
roof cast render is a is a traditional
arts and craft material
thank you councillor morgan
thank you chad i'm probably going to go
a slightly different tone than probably
a lot of
the other members of the committee um i
do understand
some of the comments um on this and i
like
i have cons i have concerns i think it's
a beautiful building on uh
councilwoman on a beautiful street um
but and i think there's then the big but
which is
do those concerns mean to oppose an
application which then potentially puts
the building at risk um
and i do think i look at this and i
think the render i have concerns about
i do think i think the applicant has
done as good a job as i think an
excellent job but i do still think it's
not going to look symmetrical in terms
of as
a as splitting it into two houses um
and it has got a significant mass but
then i have i mean i then
compared it to the rest of the street
scene i mean his next door neighbor has
suddenly gone back
from the nursery has gone back a long
way um
the house is actually very different in
terms of it's a
stunning house but it isn't we're not
looking at a set of symmetrical houses
here it is quite different in terms of
its design
um and the extension the first floor
extension
does just definitely stand out you you
would definitely know it is an extension
it doesn't fit in
um but
i do think they tried um i think i think
as much as you could do
um the building just is never going to
look like that if you do it you send it
beyond doing nothing to it
um and it's really and like we said a
lot of these applications tonight it's a
balancing act isn't it um
and i i do think when the next door
neighbor is
supporting it um
and then the commented it will be a loss
of privacy well they're the most
affected
um there's a substantial plot behind it
in terms of a garden
so i think i've really i've swayed on
this when reading the report
over the last few days and i've i have
listened to the comments and i think
i will be voting in favor of it and i
don't think i i think
it's a balance argument and i think the
balance of
preserving this building and allowing it
to be a family
set of family homes i think is worth the
the
the the loss of the fact that it is not
going to look the same as what
it did in time but heritage assets do
have to move on
as well as and and we can't stop the
clock
um so um yeah i'll be supporting the
officer recommendations tonight thank
you jeff
thank you councilman i think the
application has
proposed by councillor jerome but i'm
not certain that anyone seconded it as
well
thank you cancer i think there's been a
pretty good discussion about this now so
we moved to the votes i'll just ask
as i have done previously cycle through
you guys apparently now councillor
jerome can you confirm your vote please
i'm happy to support the recommendations
thanks joe thank you councillor
councillor tommy
have a support chair thank you
councillor councillor winston
hey recommendation officer
recommendation to grant police chair
thank you councillor councillor minis
i'm happy to support my officer
recommendation to grant thank you
thank you councilman councillor proctor
happy to support sure
thank you councillor councillor hartley
thank you chair happy support officer
recommendation to grant thank you
thank you council council morgan
i've been here approving line with
officer recommendations chair
thank you councillor councillor
accordingly
briefly left the room chair so excluded
okay and i can see councillor dr barkley
on the call as well i'm
wondering uh but she was present for the
whole discussion
uh thank you jenny i'll i'll not vote on
this one please
okay thank you councillor dr
i think that's ten voting four and two
determining that they're not going to be
voting
with that the application also my vote
uh
it won't make any difference i hope i
will vote
to support the officer's recommendation
thank you councillor holden hans 11 in
favor with
none against them that that application
is approved
um the next application for
consideration is victoria warehouse
trafford wharf road which is in page
19 of the committee report that should
be an introduction
i think from mr pearson
yes thank you chairman um if you just
play with me a second
i'll share my screen
hope everybody can see that
uh just before i start the introduction
to to this item
um members will be aware that we had
received an objection from the developer
of the
residential scheme owners number one
trafford just across the road from this
site
pleased to report that that objection
has now been withdrawn
on account of us having addressed the
various issues that they were concerned
about mainly noise related
um those issues have been addressed by
my condition
um and as you understand it the agent
speaker
against the application has chosen not
to
um so um so my introduction uh you can
see the site there
um edged yellow usually
um on the site planet sits close to
united's ground but
i'm sure members will be familiar with
the warehouses there's significant
structures
this application seeks permission for a
suite of works
um to the the complex which currently
hosts an event center
and on a 42 bedroom hotel the site
benefits from
an extent planning permission to
implement a 775 bedroom hotel
within the two warehouses on site in
conjunction with the existing arena
and events users whilst that permission
has been implemented there are only
around 40
of the hotel bedrooms have actually
developed to date
largely because the nature of the use on
site has changed over the years
so the application proposes a mix of
of new development um
together with the change of use and
refurbishment of of some of the
buildings on site
so just so you can get your whereabouts
the football grounds over here
this is the um one of the main
warehouses where the hotel currently
sits
that's that's known as the eastern
warehouse in your report
this is the western warehouse the blue
one
the uh the color building is the
relatively low rise event center that's
where where constant so most of the
conferences take place and the the sort
of amber colored building here is the
proposed car park
um so that hopefully gives you an idea
of where things
are i appreciate that's quite difficult
to see um
it's such a large uh site it's difficult
to get the whole thing
um whole thing on site but again here
that's the existing warehouse that's the
one that has the hotel in it at the
moment
so on the left as you look at it from up
from the road
uh this is the um western warehouse
there's the event center current one on
that
uh sort of amber colored um
uh extension there that's the new roof
which sits on top of the existing
and that's the multi-story car park
this drawing at the bottom shows the
site as it is now
so you can see the car park fits in that
slot where the current
surface car park is and and then you
going
over there so
um so as i say that the development
comprises the direction of this
seven story uh car park which will be
cladding core 10
which um is uh quite a trendy
sort of rusty metal uh uh as a resume
metal
appearance and it's shown there so we
sense that
this will be uh really quite a suitable
uh material
and you know for for that building
um it also includes the the
the um alteration of the uh eastern
warehouse as i mentioned before so
that's
this one down here so instead of the 775
rooms across both buildings there will
be just 200
high quality guest rooms in in that part
of the building
office space is proposed on the second
and third floors in
in this office building here um
and then i've mentioned the roof over
the existing
uh events center a new clubhouse and
running track
on top of this roof for ancillary to the
use of
of the site and then an extension
on the roof to the eastern warehouse
which provides sort of more
entertainment
the proposal includes the uh a number of
other works to the buildings um but most
of those are
relatively ancillary there are lifts
introduced at various places to improve
accessibility
and uh and a glazed entrance unit here
too
to this build so i'll just finish off
going through these slides so you can
see
how it will sit there with the
residential development number one old
trafford once that's complete
and there's a few more detailed images i
showed that one a minute ago
so that shows how the height of this
building will complement i think
the existing warehouse there's a there's
a bridge link there
from the car park at high level as well
as obviously a link
at ground floor and there we've got a
view from
from the front of the site and again you
can see how the car park will relate to
the existing warehouse
and then just a couple more there's the
western warehouse as you can see the
glazed entrance here and you can see one
of the luft
shafts here glazed lift shaft
and then i think i've just got one more
slide
shows you the view it's essentially the
canal view actually
it's taken from the road but you can see
how the
new buildings sit in the context of the
existing ones
so officers consider the principle of
the development to be acceptable
complies with the development plan which
identifies the site
as being within the wolf side strategic
location that's identified as a major
mixed-used area of regional
and international significance where
there'll be a focus on opportunities for
new economic
leisure and residential developments
the industrial aesthetic design approach
is considered to be appropriate
in keeping with steam development
includes including the use of the
quartet
buildings on site are considered to be
non-designated heritage assets
and although the proposed works on to
the site will result
in what we consider to be minor minor
adverse impacts and architectural and
historic
historic significance of the group it's
considered that the benefits of the
scheme in terms of
securing improving the existing
buildings on the site these buildings
were at one point proposed to be
demolished
a number of years back but to say that's
not the case
benefits to the local economy tourism
industry
and significant employment benefits
which you will see
all of those are considered to outweigh
this minor heritage harm
terms of noise the proposed new roof to
the arena which will sit over the top of
the existing
roof and seek to improve the acoustic
performance of the structure reduce
noise impacts to its neighbors
the condition is recommended to ensure
noise egress
from the arena is no worse than existing
reality we expect it to be
better and stone had been raised as i
mentioned earlier by the developer of
the number one
old trafford site principally over noise
issues but those concerns have been
overcome that objection has been drawn
um you'll see in the additional
information report in paragraph six to
nine
further consideration has been given to
the traffic impacts of the uses
uh and in response to concerns raised by
the highway authority
in relation to events traffic management
condition 28
additional information report requires
an event traffic management plan
now that will ensure that pedestrian and
vehicular traffic to events at the
warehouse will be managed appropriately
additional conditions also recommended
to secure an off-site parking strategy
whilst construction works take place
in the period before the car park is
made available for use
um it is as we said though is that the
recent opening of the metrolink line in
the nearby wolfside stop
transforms the accessibility of site
from from its previous
position so the development's considered
to be acceptable
and is therefore recommended for
approval
thank you spurman i'll take the screen
here thank you
mr pearson i understand the objection
has now been withdrawn so we just have
um one person speaking in favor of the
application is that
mr kevin here
yes hello hi mr cohen and you
have three minutes to speak and if you
run over i'll just politely request that
you wrap up your remarks thank you
and thank you very much chair for
allowing me to speak about
victoria warehouse victoria warehouse
is a group of three warehouses built by
the liverpool warehousing company
in the early 20th century when purchased
in 2010
it seemed destined for demolition they
were best described
as being robust muscular buildings on
massive scale
that had fallen into disrepair my
endeavors
since then have been to restore these
historic buildings and provide a
meaningful role
that secures their long-term future
victoria warehouse began
with music by design this gave victoria
warehouse relevant credibility with a
targeted demographic
that once established would attract a
corporate market
that wanted to be associated with the
image directly
or indirectly the approach enabled the
growth of the variety of events
shown in the additional information
reports with all the local
national and international benefits that
come with having this facility
the proposal is the opportunity to
enhance and preserve these historic
buildings
on this very important gateway site the
proposal has been extensively refined in
its pre-application
journey taking the advice and guidance
from traffic planners and heritage
architects
all aspects of the design have been
carefully considered to enable a
functional future role whilst restoring
historic features
there will be major employment
opportunities moving forward with this
application
presently some 282 people are employed
at the partially developed victoria
warehouse
it's expected that the high quality
hotel and conference events operation
will employ 885
people in addition the proposed office
space can accommodate 600 people
recent exhibition and conference events
have included government departments and
agencies kpmg
barclays hsbc bupa astrazeneca bmw jd
sports and
many more victoria warehouse was built
to store
and process a wide variety of goods
shipped from around the world
down the manchester ship canal to
salford keys the cargo was unloaded onto
the
trafford park railway system and
delivered to the building
the merchandise was then repackaged and
put on the bridgewater canal barges for
transportation to london and then onto
europe
the unique group of buildings are
assessed
as non-designated heritage assets
and are of historic interest
to conclude i want to emphasize that
this
proposal is an opportunity for victoria
warehouse buildings to find a long-term
role
that preserves and refurbishes their
historic features
enhances a gateway into trafford expands
upon the international reputation
and will deliver real economic benefits
moreover the proposal saves this
historic landmark property
for future generations to appreciate the
heritage
and how such operations worked in the
early 20th
century thank you very much chair
thank you mr cohen um councillor
accordingly you've indicated you opening
the discussion thank you thanks chair
mr curran and i go back uh 10 years or
so i think since i
first cycled up to albert square to have
a look at
uh his building there um
this is a journey that i i'm just really
so appreciative
victoria warehouse is a real asset to
gross hill ward
um i'm delighted that the
hotel expansion is taking place i think
the planners have done a brilliant job
as has mr curran and his architects
um one of the things i'm really pleased
about
uh which makes it so timely it's
staking out the the the mixed use of the
wharf side uh with the cultural and
tourism offer we've got a lot of
pressure for new build houses
and new bui
and the cultural side of things it has
to be a proper mixed use
and that is going to be create that buzz
so the warsaw
should have a buzz and um
mr curran and the victoria warehouse
team i've really produced that and i'm
really supportive
and i i propose acceptance thank you
jeff thank you councilman councillor
thomas
thank you chad there's not really a lot
to connect to that because mike's just
said first what i was going to say this
is an excellent building
with an excellent uh company
in situ and in my opinion an excellent
design to take it forward and
into the future and i'm more than happy
to second
the uh approval of this thank you
councillor councillor morgan
thank you chair um i can agree how often
with the two predecessor
speakers um i mean i actually the one
concern was i couldn't quite visualize
the the car park so i'd just like to
thank mr pierson for
putting those images up because that's
really really just helped clarify for
myself i
i mean this is a stunning building
absolutely i should probably
um slightly note that this was a
competition for um where we're gonna get
married so
uh it's absolutely gorgeous building um
and i would like
hate for trafford to um anything to
happen to her and
the fact that we considered demolishing
it a few years ago is
is a horrific thought um really really
is
um and yeah i'm absolutely happy to um
[Music]
support the officer recommendations
thank you councillor councillor
rigby
i think you're mute that counselor sorry
i do make important yes it's a an
ambitious application
and an exciting development and the
hotel will certainly benefit from the
upgrade
um as being said it stands at the
gateway to the borough
and we've seen warehouses
developed in other parts of the country
for alberts albert dock
liverpool and um i look forward to
supporting
this application chair thank you
councillor councillor hartman
thank you chair yeah happy to support
the the officer recommendation as well
it's um you know these these buildings
are a real a real landmark
uh they're real landmark buildings uh
and have been for some time i can
remember
i remember as a lad walking past them
stepping over the railway sleepers on
the trafford park railway to get to old
trafford and
uh and looking up at these huge
monolithic buildings probably the
biggest building i'd ever seen at that
time
um so that you know they are landmark
buildings and
uh but probably not that easy to to
convert and into a modern use and i
think this scheme does that well
uh it will have a lot less impact than
the um
the previous application for 775 rooms
um the carpark building i think i think
looks good i think it blends in well to
the heritage of the buildings
um so this is a really good opportunity
i think it's a really good scheme to
to preserve these historic buildings um
i'd support the recommendation the only
uh slight reservation i have really was
around the um
the number of ev charging points in the
in the car park so i think it's 193
space
car park and 16
i think it's 16 ev space is proposed
i know the condition um
i think the condition number 15 i think
yeah sort of asks for details to be
submitted and approved
which which might cover it but but i
think you know given the direction we're
heading
um it should be possible to to have a
you know at least 10 percent if not more
of those spaces
having ev charging points so provided
that can be
accommodated within what's proposed at
condition 15
then i'd be happy alternatively i
suppose we can make that condition more
explicit about the
um the proportion that have to be evie
but uh aside from that
i'm very supportive of the scheme so
we're happy to support the
recommendation
thank you councillor mr piston i don't
know if it's
possible if you just comment on that
issue with the proportion of parking
spaces that would have the ep
charging points on them yes certainly
i mean as you say i mean electric
vehicle charging points there's going to
be greater demand for them as time goes
on
and and at the moment we are we're
tending to
put the type the wording of the
condition as we have done to
allow for i suppose it's at the point at
which it's
uh discharged the condition is
discharged we will be taking account of
the latest
sort of government and and other
guidelines
from um from the sort of the air
pollution
uh uh people to decide what the
appropriate amount is but
i mean it might be that mr cohen is
happy to provide more than the number
that are suggested currently in the
scheme
um but that we feel that's the most
appropriate way of dealing with it
at the moment okay and
i suppose are you satisfied counselor
yeah i am that makes sense actually that
um you know obviously this development
might might take some time to do and
and i think of um you know leaving the
condition sort of open
uh it gives more scope to you know to be
up-to-date in
in terms of the proportion that that
should be um
ev charging points so yeah i'm happy
with that thanks for the explanation to
uh mr pearson thank you
and what struck me as well is that you
know there's a healthy provision of
bank storage as well contained in the
application which was
really pleasing to see and i similarly
to other members i feel really
enthusiastic about this application i
think
this is a part of trafford that's really
quite unique you know it speaks to our
a small bits of our industrial heritage
and really
development and redevelopment of that
area has in my opinion
been quite long overdue so it's nice to
see um
applications and developments coming
forward that enhance the area but they
do so with a sort of respect and a nod
to
that industrial heritage now the this
application has been
proposed and seconded and i i i'm
personally the view that we
can move on to the vote now so i'll put
it out to members and councillor jerome
can you confirm
your vote for us
thanks chair thank you councillor
councillor thomas
happy to support you thank you thank you
council councillor councillor winston
uh hugely in favor of officer
recommendations to grant police chair
thank you councillor councillor minis
thank you chair i'm i'm in favor of um
going
with the officer's recommendation to
grant thank you thank you councillor
councillor proctor
yeah really good plans uh really happy
to support thank you chad
thank you councillor councillor hartley
thank you chair happy support officer
recommendation thank you
thank you councillor councillor bigby
happy to support you
thank you councillor council accordingly
support
chair thank you council councillor
morgan
happy sport in line with officer
recommendations chair thank you
councillor
councillor holden they're
happy to support the granting
thank you councillor and councillor dr
berkley
i'm happy to support officer
recommendation to grants
i will also be voting uh in line with
office of recommendation to approve
uh and i've made that unanimous now
thank you all um next
application on the agenda the
determining
is 60 broad road and that's page 177
of the committee report pack and there
will be an
officer introduction from ms milner i
think
thank you chair just
[Music]
so the next application before members
relates to 60
broad road and a large semi-detached
property on the corner of broad road and
wally avenue in a residential area of
sale
the application proposes the demolition
of the
existing garage which is here flat roof
garage and the erection of a single
storey
home office building and which
although attached to the rear of the
property is accessed through the
basement or through the garden
um objections have been received from
three
surrounding properties including the
adjoining property
um number 62 and with concerns
over the scale of the office
and the design and also concerns
that the home office will actually be
used as a commercial premises which
would have an impact on noise and
disturbance and comings and goings to
the site
and these objections are supported by
councilor burton
in his call-in to committee whilst
officers do accept it is a large
addition to the property in terms of
depth and doesn't comply strictly with
sbd4
in terms of that depth it's considered
given that the eaves
would match the height of the existing
brick boundary wall
and would have a very shallow pitch um
on the roof
that the impact on number 62 would be
acceptable and would not lead
to a harmful impact on their amenity in
terms of
it being overbearing or resulting in a
harmful loss of light or overshadowing
and equally and this is for a home
office um ancillary to the main dwelling
an application for a commercial dwelling
would be a separate planning permission
and we are satisfied that our home
office in this location is
acceptable and therefore subject to the
conditions in the office report
recommend approval
thank you thank you ms
um i understand there's two people
speaking against them mr mullen and
councillor bulletin
um you had any agreement between
yourselves as to who'd like to speak
first
no that they didn't go first chair thank
you councillor uh
mr marlin are you with us
hey can you hear me yes this morning
thank you um you'll have three minutes
to speak and
uh if you do overstep a little bit i'll
just politely request you to wrap up
thank you
thank you chair uh there are two uh
primary issues relating to the proposed
development of 60
broad road namely compliance with the
principle set out in sbd4
and a commercial premises within a
residential area
trafford's own supplementary planning
document sbd4 gives clear guidance on
what is acceptable for
designing house extensions and
alterations it is by following these
guidelines that ensures that any
development does not breach the
council's inherent duty to safeguard the
immunity of neighbouring properties
and to protect the character and
appearance of individual properties and
residential areas as a whole
the doc this document is in place to
protect everyone in traffic and not just
those who are prepared to openly object
in theory there should be no need for
this statement to be written if the
simple guidance within spd4 was followed
and enforced
sbd4 is clear that a single story rare
extended should not extend more than
three meters from the rear of the house
the planning officer's report for
committee notes the proposed extension
has been 11 meters
however in reality it's 11.5 meters to
the edge of the roof leaves on the gable
end
i repeat 11.5 meters versus three meters
power 13 of the report makes the
comments in these specific circumstances
the development is considered to be
acceptable
acceptable to whom and if there are any
specific circumstances
then surely they would feature in sbd4
no cases made in the report as to why
such a significant derogation from the
council's own policy
should be made spd-4 is quite clear as
to how
an 11.5 meter long extension could be
accommodated
this is by increasing the spacing
between the boundary and the extension
for each additional meter of spacing the
permitted extension can increase by
a length equivalent to an equivalent
amount however in this application the
gutters of the extension are right up
against the boundary line
there is no spacing this therefore caps
the extension length as per spd4
guidelines to three meters
typically a home office for two adults
would normally require 20 square meters
of space without any need to duplicate
all normal home facilities
however in this case the proposal is
totally self-contained
with with a separate kitchen wc external
entrance doors and
with and with an internal area of 64
square meters to provide capacity of up
to six people
it is not ancillary at all to the main
dwelling for context the proposed
building is equivalent to a typical
two-bedroom apartment the proposed
development is not designed
or scaled as a home office it is a
commercial office for a successful wine
business to be constructed in the garden
of the provider's home
60 broad road is located within a high
quality residential area there are no
other commercial buildings within half a
kilometer and as such these proposals
would normally require planning
application for change of use
if such an application were submitted
it's highly unlikely that such an
application would ever be approved
planning offices observations point to
acknowledge the building is to be a home
office
and not a commercial facility and takes
reliance from the applicant as to its
current and future use
it is incumbent upon the planning
committee committee to ensure that a
planning application reflects the
correct use classification
in this case the scale and how the
building only links to the basement of
the main house
should tell the committee that it's not
a typical home office at all but a
commercial office unit
there is no relevant president that
would suggest accommodating this
application
would be appropriate and more
importantly what the community benefit
would be
for allowing such a substantial boundary
tight and orchid appendage to be built
and the unintended consequences of such
an action we respectfully look to the
committee
to reject this application thank you
chair
thank you mr marlon thanks for uh your
comments uh councillor position
you have five minutes to speak thank you
thank you thank you chair
i don't think i'll need five minutes
after mr marlon's
explained all the the objections first
of all
better make it clear that i'm not a
member of the planning committee i'm
just sitting here
as a world councillor uh having said
that chair
i i do uh acknowledge that the applicant
has made some changes since the
original application was submitted some
months ago but nevertheless
i do support mr marlon's view that this
proposal
the design of the extension is
completely out of character in a
very residential area members have
visited you'll know also houses around
there are large victorian or edwardian
properties
and this i must say rather uh
utilitarian extension
doesn't fit in with those at all
mr marlon's mentioned about spd4 uh the
councillors or the officer's own report
say that this is
the 11 meters is vastly in excess of the
limits applied by spd4 and it's not just
marginal it
is well in excess and i think that alone
should be enough to refuse the
application
um the final point is i'm still
concerned about the office
i know it's down as a home office i'm
not quite sure how you define that
but to me it's particularly because it's
an external
door external access it looks like a
commercial office
and i don't think if this was granted
how would the council monitor what the
office how
the office was used and what it was used
for in practical terms we just haven't
got the staff to be doing that
and to me i'm afraid i have to believe
that this
this office is intended for commercial
use because that's what it looks like
it's designed like that
it's not an integral part of the house
it's
there is access from the house but also
access from outside
i have a home home office i suspect most
people on here do
but it's not external to their house and
separate from the house
so socher i i do hope the committee
could understand
the objection of mr marlondy's neighbors
and refuse this application
thanks chair thank you councillor thanks
um i believe there's katherine ludlum uh
with us as well to speak in favor of the
application
good evening chair and members i am kath
ludlam a chartered town planner and
conservation consultant
i am speaking on behalf of the
applicants mr mrs gray
and in support of the officer's
recommendation to approve
my clients have lived at 60 broad roads
since 1992
and have worked from home since 1999
using the basement as an office the
nature of their business is a specialist
high-end vintage wine suppliers to
prestigious clients in the uk
and abroad this is an online business
and customers do not visit the site
stock is not held on site it is held in
bonded warehouses elsewhere
and there is a minimal number of
deliveries by standard carriers
there are three family members working
and no other staff are employed
the business has operated this at this
level for the past 21 years
with no complaints from any source
regarding traffic
parking noise or disturbance
the proposed home office will remain as
an ancillary residential use
this is not a commercial proposal
it will provide a healthier working
environment with improved sunlight
daylight and space for this family
such working from home is a sustainable
practice
which is actively encouraged by the
government both local and nationally
the proposal retains the three existing
car spaces at the weir
and provides a new turning facility so
there is no longer any need to reverse
onto wally avenue as a presence
there will be no additional occupiers
vehicle movements
parking requirements or deliveries above
the existing
the proposal is cited on the footprint
of the existing garage and hard standing
with no loss of green space and is well
screened by a mature holly hedge and
brown
boundary brick walls it extends further
than the length of the garage by 4.5
meters
and is 1.5 meters higher at the ridge
increasing the footprint by 35 square
meters
just 6 site coverage which is modest in
relation to the large size plot on the
house itself
the design has been amended as requested
by the planners to be reduced in size
and is architecturally sympathetic the
existing victorian dwelling
in terms of the impact on neighbouring
properties it should be noted that both
of which have been considerably extended
as the photographs indicate not
sympathetically
number 62 broad road the proposal
projects 4.5 meters further along the
common boundaries in the existing garage
and the eaves are level with the lowest
part of the existing boundary wall
the ridge is four meters high between
2.5 meters and four meters from the
common boundary
the only visible element from 62 broad
road
will be the receding shallow pitched
roof plane
this would not result in a visual impact
or be overbearing
although exceeding the guideline figure
in spd4
it complies that in that it does not
adversely affect amenity
as advised in the committee report
number five wally avenue the proposal is
five metres from the common boundary and
ten meters from the side elevation
with an intervening two meter high brick
boundary wall
and is sighted due north of number nine
and has no windows in the gable
elevation
the recommendation is to prove this
application and members are respectfully
requested to follow the officer's clear
advice thank you very much
thank you ms ludlum um i don't think i
can see anyone as having
indicated in the chat that they'd like
to open the discussion are any members
um looking to contribute here
no um well i mean
i i appreciate the remarks that have
been made by mr marlon councillor button
and
miss ludlum i have to say because i i
found myself agreeing
with both uh contributions that we've
all contributions that we've received
tonight i think ms ludlum highlighted
that you know the plot that
uh the application with the development
would sit in it is actually quite
sizable
um and i do think that it's possible for
that plot to accommodate an extension or
a
home office um however i think in
council of bulletin's contribution
and mr marlon's contribution they both
seemed quite
um strongly of the view that actually
the non-compliance with spd4
in terms of the extent of the extension
um
it's not just a marginal breach that
that view seems to be that it's actually
quite a significant breach and i don't
know ms milner if he had any sort of
um reflection on the backgrounds of
their objection
thank you chair yes uh spd4 is is our
guidance and and we do use that
to to guide um all decisions regarding
house extensions
and generally we we do stick to that
guidance
quite strictly but the guidance is there
to be taken
alongside material planning
considerations and material planning
considerations
include the existing conditions on site
the existing conditions on site are that
there is a 2.3 meter high brick wall
along the boundary with 62 broad road
and therefore
if the eaves of the extension do not go
above that height
we have to ask ourselves what is the
harm on the what is the impact and what
is the harm to the amenity of the
adjacent um occupiers and sbd that
for is not to be um purely um
imposed um without considering those
material considerations
and also you'll see from the um the
plans that the the design of the
property has an asymmetrical roof
and which means that the eaves are much
lower well
they are lower on the side with the
adjoining property
and because of the roof slope there is
quite a distance between the eaves and
the ridge height
which again takes the height away from
that shared common boundary
and as such we don't feel that it would
have an overbearing impact and
harmful above the existing situation on
site
where but therefore we're quite
confident whilst it doesn't strictly
comply with
or doesn't comply with sbd4 there are
material considerations
that dictate otherwise
thank you mr mona thank you for so
clarifying that um
council accordingly you've indicated
it's speed
uh thanks chair i'm happy to propose uh
accepting the officer's recommendation
after hearing that
um it it is an
unusual plot um
i doubt if this extension would fit in
many houses
within trafford that that site is
particularly unusual
and on that basis i do think that we can
introduce flexibilities
to it does fit
basically that the extension does fit
and i'm happy to accept that and
i i do take the view that the officers
have treated this
objectively and um i
i'm happy to uh propose acceptance of
that
thanksgiving thank you councillor cancer
hartley
thank you yeah i'm thinking of a similar
mind as a councillor accordingly
it's a difficult one because because the
the size of the extension
is well in excess of the of the
distances in
in spd4 i think um i think i think the
advice we had from miss miller was
really helpful actually about you know
those are
guidelines that they're not sort of
fixed distances and we do see
applications where those
those distances are are exceeded so i i
think you need to look at the
the development in in context at the
site so
uh although it does exceed by a long way
those those distances in sbd4 i agree
with council accordingly i think that
it does fit into the site it is an
unusual site because it's a
corner plot and also very
very deep so you've got a very long side
elevation
um and also the nature of the property
with high boundary walls
as is so although when i first looked at
it i thought
well this is way too long it's way in
excess of the guidelines
um but actually having having been to
the site
and looked at the elevations the the
impact on the on the street scene and i
think the impact on amenity is is
minimal actually so
um i i'd also be happy to uh support the
officer recommendation to to grant
the chair thank you council councillors
i think spd4 3.3.2
does allow each case to be considered
individually if i think i'm right
um and it does allow us to look at the
specific nature of the locality
and existing buildings to be taken into
account
um i don't know if that's just for
corner plots or whether it
includes this plot also but if you do
look at some of the objections i do tend
to agree with officers
as other councillors have stated
but i don't think there's any
overbearance
um there's no issues with parking
um and i don't think there are any i
think the office use i think a lot of
people
are going to be
altering their houses to work from home
as we know um
society is changing because of covert 19
and more people will be looking to work
at home and
kind of alter their homes in this type
of way
so though it is a very difficult one um
i probably will be
uh siding with councillor accordingly
and councillor hartley on this one
thank you chair thank you councillor um
councilman rigby
yes thanks chair um and thanks again to
ms milner for her explanation on spd4
it um it was really helpful the only
i mean i appreciate the representation
that's been made
you know everybody likes to defend their
property but
the only other the other issue which had
been raised was the
the sort of threat as it were
of it being made into a commercial
office well we can't make
decisions at planning on what may happen
to a building
we've got to make decisions surely on
what has been applied for
and what is being used for um but no i
i've been swung entirely and i'll be
agreeing with the officer's
recommendation
thank you councillor rigby and i can't
see anyone else's having indicated that
they'd like to
speak if i'm wrong please
do so now the application has been
proposed by council accordingly but i
don't think it's been seconded by any
member
yeah secondly situation
thank you cancel the weekly okay we'll
move to the vote then
and as previously i'll just go around my
screen and
thank you councillor councillor thomas
happy to support the recommendations
chad
thank you councillor councilwind stanley
uh thanks chair
happy to um uh support officer's
recommendation to grant
thank you council councilman minis happy
to support the
officer's recommendation thank you to
grant
thank you councillor procter report
officer recommendation to grant
thank you councillor councillor hartley
thanks chair support officer
recommendations
grant thank you councillor councilman
bigby
happy to support the officer's
recommendation to grant thank you
councillor cancer call on dingley
uh so support support because the
recommendation
counselor morgan
support the recommendation to grant
thank you councillor and counselor dr
barclay
what officer recommendation to grant
and i shall also be voting to support
officer recommendation
to grant and make that a unanimous
decision in committee
that application is approved um i think
we're out of time
in terms of being able to proceed to any
more of the applications on the agenda
um i'm sure the democratic services can
confirm that
[Music]
they're not german but yes we are out of
time
we we can't we can't take any any more
items this evening
yeah but um applicants who were waiting
um i understand will be contacted about
a deferred meeting
next week yes i think we can
we can confirm that that will be the
same time the same
date next week thursday the 17th we will
confirm the time of that meeting for you
can i just say that clashes with a
licensing panel which i'm chair of so
i won't be able to pretend both clearly
would you be happy submitting a written
statement to be ready i
already have yeah i already have to
michelle so i'm happy for that to be
read
out right i will sorry i'll be on the
same meeting i'm on the
licensing uh school committee
um okay what will communicate to members
answer the applicants what
what the arrangements will be yeah okay
i was going to ask is there any chance
it could be later than four o'clock
okay yeah sure we'll discuss it after
yeah
so shall we chairman close the meeting
and then agree the time with with the
members present
that's great thank you